[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir le 78 en direct entre 18 et 19h
nous faisons le point sur l'actualité
locale l'actualité du département nous
reviendrons sur le bilan du Téléton sur
la fracture à l'UMP sur le plan neige
également dans le département sur la
colère aussi des entrepreneurs qui
voient la contribution financière cette
année en forte hausse et puis avec
Anthony r comme chaque lundi le point
sur le sport le point sur les sports
bonsoir Anthony bonsoir Wilfried ce soir
au programme elles sont revenues de
l'enfer au paradis elles ce sont les
participantes cinquantinoises au raid de
l'Arbre Vert qui vient de se dérouler
sur l'île Maurice nous invitons nos
invités nous délivront leurs premières
impressions après cette compétition
unique j'ai aussi testé pour vous il y a
quelques jours le taekwendo je me suis
risqué sur le tatami avant ça s'est bien
passé je suis en un seul morceau je suis
je suis allé donc sur le tatami avec les
takondoistes avant les championnats
régionaux d'île-de-fance des séquences
qui mériteront le coup d'œil et puis
comme chaque fin de chronique les
résultats du weekend on reviendra sur
tout ça bien sûr et j'ai hâte de voir
ces images d'entraînement du taekwendo
Anthony le sport ce sera en seconde
partie de cette édition pour le moment
voici les principaux titres en images
les reportages à découvrir en ce 10
décembre les premiers flocons de neige
sont tombés en fin de semaine dernière
sans surprise les services de saleuse
étaient déjà mis en place et ceux depuis
la mi-nvembre les leçons de la pagaille
de l'iver 2010 ont été bien tirées nous
ferons aussi un point sur l'action mené
sur l'ensemble de notre secteur avec nos
invités vous le voyez qui sont déjà sur
ce plateau ce weekend 26e édition du
Téléton dans les ivelines 199
manifestation programmées certaines
villes sont toujours très contributrices
c'est le cas de manilé hamoo plus de
20000 € déjà récolté attrape pour la
première fois une animation était aussi
proposée le club de basket de trappe a
signé une victoire ce samedi sur son
parquet face à Calais une victoire à
l'arrachée 64 à 63 l'occasion aussi pour
le club de renouveler son partenariat
avec deux entre entreprise partenaire de
longue date le budget du club s'élève à
300000 € le plus petit budget de
National 2 et ce weekend concours des
archers de Guill encour on en parlera
aussi lors de la page sport un concours
qualificatif pour les championnats de
France 260 archers étai présents un mot
sur l'élection de Miss France qui s'est
déroulé ce weekend puisque'une étudiante
de l'Université de Versailles
saint-contin en Yveline y particip Joy
lartig 21 ans étudiante en licence de
droit elle se présentait avec l'écharpe
de Miss orleéanis malheureusement elle
n'a pas réussi à convaincre le jury ni à
séduire les téléspectateurs elle n'a pas
eu l'occasion de seisser jusqu'en finale
des 33 candidates c'est Miss Bourgogne
si vous avez suivi l'élection qui s'est
imposé félicitations tout de même à
l'ivelinoise d'adoption pour sa
participation l'autre rendez-vous
télévisuel de ce weekend c'était bien
évidemment le Téléton les promesses de
don sont moins élevées mais avant de
recevoir dans une quinzaine de minutes
les organisateur au niveau départemental
le point sur la mobilisation les
principales lignes attrape et à Manil
àot avec Joan assoudri et Guillaume cors
c'est une première pour le club de
basket de trappe des paniers au profit
du Téléton les enfants ont commencé il y
a à peu près 20 minutes et on est en
train de compter les les paniers bon ils
commencec un petit peu à fatiguer ça se
voit mais puis ils sont très excités
donc ça se voit aussi ça pique pas trop
mais ça va venir je pense et oui les
jeunes de trappe et des clubs
environnant auront tenu une heure
nombreux de paners réalisé plus de 2000
grâce à leur investissement un chèque de
800 € a pu être reversé au Téléton
autre commune autre ambiance mais
toujours pour la même cause amaniamo
l'association Objectif Téléton a
sollicité la comédienne Virginie Lemoine
de diverses façons je participe chaque
année au Téléton j'ai toujours fait des
choses une fois je su avec mon chien une
fois faire des reportages à Lyon j'ai
fait toutes sortes de choses et donc de
donner un tout petit peu de son temps
simplement pour pour soi-même bien
reprendre conscience de ça avant même de
rendre hommage à tous les bénévoles qui
eux très sérieusement et
considérablement donnent de leur temps
et rendre hommage au aux malades qui
sont toujours d'une dignité absolue
c'est quelque chose d'essentiel le
téton
ça permet d'avoir des nouveaux
médicaments et bien que la science
avance plus facilement Christophe modu
est atteint de sclérose en plaque sa
mère s'investit depuis de nombreuses
anné dans l'Association manicoise pour
le Téléton qui compte actuellement 25
bénévoles on commence à travailler en
avril on a des collecteurs on a des
personnes qui s'occupent plus de
l'administratif on a des gens qui
s'occupent de la décoration on a des
gens qui s'occupent de la technique de
l'organisation de la mise en place dans
le gymnase chacun a un rôle bien défini
en fait avec objectif Téléton d'autres
association participe à l'événement au
programme spectacle de danse
démonstration de sport et activités en
genre ils ont un peu fait toutes les
animations qu'est-ce que tu as préféré
tir à l'arc à et toi qu'est-ce que tu as
préféré ça tu as gagné quelque chose oui
tu as gagné quoi ça je trouve qu'il y a
moins de monde que l'année dernière oui
petre la crise on espère faire mieux que
l'année dernière mais voilà on sait pas
vous avez fait combien l'année dernière
qu'on a une petite idée on a fait un peu
plus de 300 € aujourd'hui les bénévoles
de manie peuvent être fiers ils ont
récolté 52 € presque autant qu'en 2011
mais il s'agit pour l'instant d'un
chiffre provisoire tous espèrent
atteindre et même dépasser la somme de
l'an
[Musique]
dernier la neige est tombée sur les
ivelines en fin de semaine dernière mais
rien d'inquiétant nous sommes bien loin
de l'épisode neigeux de décembre 2010
avec la PAA et qui s'en était suivi
chacun semble prêt aujourd'hui à faire
face c'est ce que nous allons voir avec
nos deux invités Muriel Bti bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes directrice des
infrastructures de l'agglomération de 50
ans en iveline et Claude pignon bonsoir
à vous directeur technique directeur des
services techniques pardon à Montini le
Breton tout d'abord comment se sont
passés les derniers jours avec le retour
de la neige vous avez été mobilisé en
fin de semaine dernière vous étiez sur
le terrain tout à fait
oui fortement puisque tout était bien
prévu on a analysé la météo fait des
patrouilles sur le terrain vérifier nos
décisions qu soient les meilleures nous
sommes coordonnés VO et surtout
coordonnés avec les diff grand commune
de l'agglomération voà parce
qu'effectivement on vous a fait venir
sur le plateau tous les deux ce soir
pour voir un peu plus clair aussi sur
les missions de chacun parce qu'il y a
le plan neige dans les communes il y a
celui de l'agglomération de
saintquanttin en Yveline par exemple
c'est une des agglomérations du
département et puis il y a aussi le plan
neige au niveau départemental mené par
le conseil général on va commencer par
l'agglomération quelles sont proprement
parlé vos missions vos compétences
lorsque survient un épisode neigeux
alors on gère en fait 200 km de voies
qui sont de gestion communautaire ce
sont les voies primaires les voies
principales en fait de l'agglomération
et voies secondair
donc que nous entretenons et donc les
cheminements piéton qui sont aux abords
quand il y a pas de Riverin direct et
puis également les trois gares de
l'agglomération et donc ça c'est c'est
le plan sur les SEP communes qui concern
ça concerne les 7 communes 200 km sur
SEP communes et en ce qui concerne
montinil bretonne alors son classa donc
entretien pour nous gère 20 km de voirie
et nous 50 km de voir ville vous
intervenez sur les trottoirs aussi par
exemple oui le trottoir en sachant que
ce sont les riverins qui doivent dégager
leur trottoir voilà parce ça aussi c'est
important Gou par tout à fait ou
responsabilité en cas de en cas de neige
ils ont tendance à tout remettre sur le
sur la commune non non c'est également à
eux de d'entretenir leur trottoir et il
y a donc cette coordination entre vos
services ceux de l'agglomération et puis
il y a aussi le Conseil général des
Yvelines le plan neige est en vigueur
jusqu'au 17 mars un petit rappel avec ce
reportage que nous avons réalisé la
semaine dernière et qui reprécise les
grandes lignes de ce
plan chacun se souvient des épisodes
neigeux de l'hiver 2010 et des
automobilistes bloqués en fin
d'après-midi la leçon a été retenue et
depuis 2 ans les services plus que
mobilisé pendant ces mois d'hivers un
plan vigilance a été mis en place dans
le département depuis quelques jours les
équipes de techniciens et cadres sont
mobilisés en astreinte 7 jours sur 7 et
24 heures sur 24 cette année comme l'an
passé les équipes du département vont
s'appuyer sur la participation de 15
agriculteurs afin d'être le plus réactif
possible en zone rurale comme urbaine
pendant l'hiver dernier le département a
connu de forts épisodes neigeux les
équipes de la Direction des routes et
des transports sont intervenus 10 fois
et 1900 tonnes de sel ont été utilisé
dès les premiers flocons de neige les
usagers pourront consulter les dernières
alertes de circulation ou de dénaigement
sur le site internet du conseil général
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner avec
votre
smartphone voilà pour le plan neig en ce
qui concerne le département des Yvelines
comment vous travaillez avec le le
département justement par exemple
l'agglomération se coordonne aussi tout
à fait nous sommes en relation directe
avec les agents du département auquel
nous avons loué de très bonnes tion nous
sommes ENF nous avons déjà partagé un
certain nombre de sections de voix à
déneéiger pour qu'on soit plus réactif
c'est dire que des voies qui pourrait
être à l'aglo sont dénéigés
ponctuellement par le Conseil Général et
inversement ce qui évite des des des
demi-tours ou des des tours ga une perte
de temps pour les sleuses et puis
également nous avons systématiquement en
fait les relevés météo enfin leur
relevés de sortie ou non nous également
nous leur faisons part si nous sortons
ou non comme ça on se coordonne au mieux
par rapport à notre analyse météo et
aujourd'hui est-ce que tout ça est
véritablement efficace je repense
toujours à 2010 et je pense que je suis
pas le seul pour ceux qui sont restés
bloqués aujourd'hui une telle situation
une telle pagaille comme il y a 2 ans ce
n'est pas envisageable c'est pas
possible je pense qu'on est déjà on a
optimisé notre coordination euh aussi
bien avec les villes qu'avec le
département et la Drif hein puisquil y a
des des voies également qui
appartiennent à l'État donc là-dessus
nousous sommes bien coordonnés nous
avons avec les communes audionférence
systématique et qui peut être récurrente
dans la dans la journée et dans la nuit
pour prendre des décisions et les bonne
en préventif parce qu'il faut travailler
essentiellement en préventif quand il y
a des gros événements et puis aprèsà et
ensuite on a bien vu que le plus
important c'était les patrouilles de
terrain aussi bien je dirais de la part
de la commune des communes et puis de
l'agglomération nous avons une astrinte
hivernale qui travaille en collaboration
avec les astreintes des services des
communes justement pour se mobiliser
ensemble pour voir ensemble les
problématiques terrain et être le plus
réactif possible et éventuellement
modifier nos circuits de salage en
conséquence et c'est très souple au
quotidien vous adapte chaque jour tout à
fait oui une prise de météo échange
enfin pour revenir sur le phénomène de
l'année dernière je veux dire c'était
quand même un phénomène exceptionnel qui
est arrivé il y a 2 ans oui qui est
arrivé je veux dire en plus je crois que
c'était un vendredi après-midi là on
avait beau être réactif c'est tombé trop
d'un coup je veux dire là enfin de toute
façon il y a des situationstion des
situations exceptionnelles on a beau
tout prévoir planifier coordonner il y
aura toujours le le
phénomène et pour intervenir justement
il y a eu certains gymnases qui avaient
été réquisitionnés par exemple qui
intervient dans ce domaine là c'est les
communes les agglomérations qui
travaillent c'est plutôt les les
communes par ce sont les communes oui
l'ébergement quel plan existe quel plan
a été mis en place justement sur tout il
y a toute une procédure je veux dire le
nous c'est le le gymnase Pierre de
Coubertin qui est décrit comme un un
lieu de d'hébergement quoi ça ça fait
des années que c'est comme ça alors ça
ça concerne aussi tous les particuliers
qui utilisent la route pour rentrer chez
eux il y a les entreprises aussi vous
travaillez avec les entreprises vous les
contacter éventuellement pour avoir des
dépars échelonnés de salariés si c'est
possibleit tout le monde n pas sur les
routes au même moment tout à fait grand
leçon du du problème d' y a 2 ans c'est
c'est les entreprises qui avaient lâché
leur leur personnel sur les sur les
routes sans sans prévoir queils seraient
tous bloqués là on va essayer justement
d'anticiper nous avons leurs coordonnées
nous les avons saisis ils ont un plan
avec le centre d'éberchement qui sera
bien décrit gymnas Pier le Coubertin si
les gens venaient être pris dans la dans
la neige on se souvient que du côté du
Technocentre Renault les salariés
étaient restés bloqués toute la nuit
là-bas là il y a également une une
nouvelle méthode qui a été mis en place
un nouveau système aujourd'hui on peut
alerter donc l'ensemble des des
entreprises via des SMS puisquil faut
également faire redescendre l'aler
préfectorale qui n'était pas forcément
redescendu auprès de tout le monde et on
a ce moyen cet outil qui peut être
rapide et plus efficace justement pour
informer les entreprises aujourd'hui
combien de personnes sont mobilisées
pour l'agglomération déjà ça a
correspond avec le prestataire extérieur
une trentaine de personnes quand même et
en ce qui concerne montinil bretonneur
en plus 50 plus le prestataire extérieur
donc au total on a 80 personnes dans ce
qui concerne Montini et puis
l'agglomération qui interviennent plus
toutes celles qui travaillent aussi dans
les autres communes de Saint-Quentin en
niveline CE ce soir on fait un focus sur
l'action notamment à Montini le
Bretonneux nous sommes allés vous voir
sur le terrain reportage Catherine
zulato Patrick Jacques de
dixm vendredi matin premier flocon de
neige dans le département et première
mise en action pour le dispositif
viabilité hivernale active depuis la
mi-novembre et jusqu'au 15 mars pour
l'agglomération ctinoise tout ce pil
voilà pour ce reportage que vous avez
déjà pu découvrir on va juste se caler
sur le bon Magneto et on va pouvoir se
rendre à monil bretonne voir comment
vous travaillez sur le
terrain
vendredi matin premier flocon de neige
dans le département et première mise en
action pour le dispositif viabilité
hivernale active depuis la mi-nvembre et
jusqu'au 15 mars pour l'agglomération
cantinoise tout se pilote depuis cet
entrepôt à trppe c'est là qu''est stocké
le sel pour l'hiver 1200 tonnes on a 10
camions
camions donc pour la kqu et un camion
pour la ville de Montin breneux à
Montini le Bretonneux justement c'est
Patrick ratau le responsable de la
voirie qui a l'œil sur le planning de 50
agents mobilisable 24 heures sur 24 et 7
jours sur 7 chacun a donc une tâche bien
spécifique et un secteur à traiter dans
la ville et dans un quartier bien défini
les leçons de l'hiver 2010 avec son lot
de véhicules bloqués sur les chaussées
ont été bien tirés des bulletins
d'alerte météo sont édités dès que
besoin et chaque équipe dispose d'une
cartographie des zones adénéigé on s'est
également équipé de nouveaux engins
comme les mis enins de salage de Boirie
qui sont qui font en hiver du salage et
dans d'autres saisons d'autres
prestations sur la ville l'hydrogommage
traitement des graffitis plus de
véhicules et des engins plus performants
Sylvain charriier et chauffeur saleur
tout est automatisé depuis ce petit
boîtier jaune à l'intérieur du camion
vous pouvez
doser comment le le pourcentage de selle
par rapport au mè Carr vous pouvez voir
la largeur du du du jet vous pouvez
aussi régler donc bah pour la saumure un
système expérimental sur montinide
breteneux c'est un mélange de sel d'eau
qui fait que quand on quand on le met
par terre la neige enfin normalement n
pas repassé quoi la
neige ne tient pas ne tient pas par
terre une bouillie de sel comme
l'appellent les spécialistes 80 % de sel
solide et 20 % de sel liquide un procédé
qui sera actif à partir de la
mi-décembre pas de neige annoncée dans
les prochains
jours pas de neige dans les prochains
jours vous confirmez peut-être
éventuellement quelques flocons quelques
flocons cette nuit quelques flocons qui
vont arriver cette nuit la météo évolue
effectivement assez vite rien
d'inquiétant pour cette nuit les saluses
sont déjà passé pas besoin je pense
prage justement parlerit des des
bouilles de sel à la fin de ce reportage
c'est la recette miracle cette année un
petit peu bah c'est un procédé qui qui
qui est nouveau et qui devrait faire
faire des économies de de sel en
pollution ça devrait donc
mettre 30% peu près moins de de sel les
VOO donc et une plus grande efficacité
sur le verglat c'est un des objectifs
aussi à atteindre puisque le sel sec n'a
pas d'impact sur le Vergl donc là on
devrait pouvoir gérer beaucoup plus
facilement les problèmes de glissance
alors avec cette bouillie de sel
également vous disiez Mo- 30 % de sel ça
veut dire que c'est plutôt positif aussi
pour l'entretien de la voirie après
parce que on en parle assez rarement
mais les gens constatent il y a souvent
après des des les voiries sont
endommagées des nid de poules voilà qui
qui se creusent il faut réparer la
voirie après là il y en aura moins
ellement cette année les dégradations
sur Var c'est plutôt lié au gel que sel
non le le sel c'est plutôt son sur
ouvrage d'art ou c'est pas toujours bien
prconisé quoi là c'est bon pour
l'environnement qui a moins de sel moins
de sel donc moins de consommation et
aussi le problème de de stockage de sel
qu'il avait eu il y a un an et demi hein
donc ça nous permet aussi d'être d'avoir
un stock plus important puisqu'on en
consomme moins voilà pour les recettes
qui sont utilisées du côté de
l'agglomération de 50 on v un tel plan
et travailler depuis quand depuis quand
vous intervenez vous préparez cet
épisode hivernal tout au long de l'année
vous y pensez l'été même quand il fait
beau on pense on est en pleine neige en
général l'été je sais pas c'est pareil
je pense au service technique même le
fruit d'une longue expérience parce que
tous les ans nous améliorons je veux
dire on se c'est pas du jour au
lendemain qu'on dit tiens il faut qu'on
sal il y a il y a tout une préparation
il c'est vraiment une il faut anticiper
quoi c'est vraiment rien rien que les
marchés publics à lancer puisquon a un
nouveau prestataire donc il fallait
lancher ce marché public et ça prend
beaucoup de temps voilà parce qu'il faut
mettre en concurrence les entreprises
pour économiser parce que ça coûte très
cher un tel plan est-ce que vous avez
les chffr en tête de ce que ça peut
représenter ouais c'est c'est une belle
somme rien qu'en forfait nous on est
autour de 500000 € en forfait d'assrinte
en fait hors prestation de salage pour
intervenir et pour vous puissiez rouler
sur les routes il y a tout de même on le
mentionnait tout à l'heure des
précautions à prendre pour les usagers
hein chacun bien évidemment doit se
méfier avant de prendre sa voiture ou
d'utiliser un trottoir aussi quelle
précaution prenez-vous c'est la question
que nous sommes allés vous poser
aujourd'hui dans les rues 51 qutinig
déjà on se couvre bien les mains les
gants pour les enfants et puis on achète
aussi du du sel pour mettre sur le
trottoir met un vêtement plus chaud quoi
en fait soit des cachoreeilles des gants
surtout les gantscharpe euh B non pas
spécialement à part prendre le bus pour
pas prendre la voiture comme il disait
l'autre fois voilà c'est tout en plus
bon l'épisode a été assez bref donc
voilà j'ai des pneus tout neufs sur ma
voiture aussi non du tout du tout non
c'est ouais
pourquoi
parce que parce qu'il y a pas besoin
forcément et que que voilà quoi faut
juste faire attention au marche et puis
on y
va on reste chez soi voilà comme ça on
n'est pas concerné par la neige c'est
peut-être encore plus simple vous êtes
prêts pour les prochains jours on
parlait de la neige quelques flocons
tout à l'heure éventuellement plutôt
vers mercredi aussi un petit peu plus
est-ce qu'il y a un épisode n jeux
important peu plus froid je crois en fin
de
semaine moins 4 là mercredi même déjà
cette nuit on sent qu'il fait froid les
Salus vont sortir dans les prochains
jours sans doute mais si c'est le cas on
est prêtifond très bien merci d'être
venu nous rassurer sur ce plateau merci
donc à tous les deux Murielle Bti
directrice des infrastructures
communauté d'agglomération de
Saint-Quentin et Claude pignon directeur
des services techniques de Montini le
Bretonneux la CFE la contribution
foncière des entreprises qui fait
toujours polémique cette taxe qui
remplace la taxe professionnelle depuis
2 ans a forcément augmenté une hausse
allant parfois jusqu'à 500 % des
entrepreneurs à 50 ans en iveline on
appelle maintenant à l'agglomération de
50 ans nieline qui vote ce taux
d'imposition la situation ce temps les
explications de Catherine zulato CFE
cotisation foncière des entreprises
trois lettres qui ont fait bondir les
commerçants cinquantinois cette
contribution entrée en remplacement de
la taxe professionnelle s'avère pour
certains petits commerçants bien plus
lourde que prévu avec des cotisations
qui ont doublé voire triplé depuis
l'année dernière jeudi soir réunis en
conseil syndical les élus de
l'agglomération ont fait voter une
motion à l'unanimité pour leur permettre
de modifier la délibération du 22
septembre 2011 qui fixait les modalités
cette motion se tradu en vote lors du
prochain conseil syndical le 18 décembre
en attendant des consignes ont été
données par la Direction des finances
pour permettre plus de souplesse dans le
paiement de la cotisation et les
commerçants de leur côté manifesteront
demain mardi à 15h30 devant l'hôtel
d'agglomération